اعلنت تركيا موافقتها على انضمام السويد
الى حلف شمال الاطلسي الذي يعقد قمه في
ليتوانيا هيمن عليها البحث في سبل دعم
اوكرانيا في مواجهه روسيا وقال البيت
الابيض انه يعتزم تزويد انقره بمقاتلات اف
16 في سياق ترحيب واشنطن وعواصم غربيه
بالخطوه التي ربطتها بالموافقه على
انضمامها للاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف نفهم الموافقه
التركيه على انضمام السويد الى النيتو في
ضوء التجاذبات التي احاطت بالامر وما الذي
تعانيه بالنسبه لتوسع الحلف وسياسه الباب
المفتوح وكيف ستتعاطى موسكو مع هذه الخطوه
وما مستقبل مساري انضمام اوكرانيا وانضمام
تركيا للاتحاد الاوروبي ومنعكاسات التقدم
في المسارين اقليميا ودوليا وما الملامح
المستقبليه للتحالفات في ضوء هذه
المتغيرات في مواقع وادوار دول الغربيه في
سياق المواجهه بين روسيا والنيتو وكيف
ستنعكس على اجنده واشنطن في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
عضوا جديد ينضم الى حلف شمال الاطلسي في
خطوه ما كان لها ان تتم لولا موافقه من
تركيا التي اعطت الضوء الاخضر للسويد بعد
مفاوضات وصفت بالطويله والشاقه سرعت
العواصم الغربيه للترحيب بالقرار التركي
وسط اسئله عما سيكون ثمنا لها مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي جاك سوليفان قال ان
الرئيس بايدن يعتزم السماح بتزويد تركيا
بمقاتلات اف 16
بالتنسيق مع الكونجرس الطموح التركيه يشمل
كذلك مطلبا قديما جديدا والانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي سولفان اكد ان واشنطن
تدعم مطلب انقره في الانضمام الى النادي
الاوروبي بين ان تحقيق ذلك يرتبط هو الاخر
بضوء من عواصم القرار الاوروبي المستشار
الالماني قال ان الاتحاد الاوروبي معني
بتطوير العلاقات مع تركيا وهو ما اوصت به
قمته الاخيره وكاله الاناضول نقلت عن
مسؤول تركيا رفيع قوله تركيا تلقت دعما
كاملا لمساري عضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي ورفع
العقوبات وتحرير التاشيرات على الجانب
الاخر عربت روسيا عن انزعاجها من القرار
التركي فقد قال الكريم انضمام السويد الى
حلف الناتو ستكون له تداعيات على الامن
القوميه الروسيه وسيتم اتخاذ اجراءات
بشانه المتحدث باسم الكرملين
لا احد من الاوروبيين يرغب برؤيه تركيا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وينبغي الا تكون لدى
تركيا اي اوهام في هذا الصدد
[موسيقى]
بمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
دكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه
والعلاقات الدوليه ومن باريس ايضا دكتور
زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه
الامريكيه في باريس مرحبا بكما دكتور خليل
ابدا معك بعد مفاوضات شاقه ومضنيه ل 14
شهرا توافق تركيا على انضمام السويد لحلف
ما الذي ستجنيه
انقره من وراء هذه الموافقه
اولا التحايل حضرتك سلمى والدكتور زياد
ولا كل المشاهدين انا اعتقد الموافقه
التركيه تاتي عدد المتغيرات متغير الاول
يتعلق بسعي تركيا لاصلاح علاقتهم مع
الاوروبيه خاصه بعد التوتر التي حدث على
مدار السنوات الماضيه وخاصه بعد فوز
اردوغان بوليرسيه جديده محاوله اصلاح
العلاقات مع اوروبا الامر الاخر متعلق
باستخدام مساله
مكاسب المكسب الاول متعلق كمجال قبل قليل
بالاسراع في اتمام صفقه طائرات المقاتلين
التي توقفت قبل حوالي عامين من الان وهناك
الان سعي كبير جدا من البيت الابيض
للتعامل مع الكونجرس والضغط عليه من اجل
تمام هذه الصفقه هنعلم جميعا انه من الصعب
يتم تمرين الصفقه بدون وجود وجود موافقه
من الكونجرس عليها وسمعنا بالامس تصريحات
جيده من قبل
العلاقات الخارجيه
للتحدث وقال ربما هناك امكانيه
خلال اسبوع من الان الامر الثاني متعلق
بالتاكيد على الالتزام السويد
لساقها مع المواقف الاوروبيه وبالتالي نحن
ازاي مرحله جديده مرحله جديده العلاقات
العلاقات ما بين
اتحاد الاوروبي دكتور زياد ماجد
ترى التركي لانضمام
السويد الى حلف الناتو وفي ضوء ايضا ظرف
اقتصادي اقتصادي داخل تركيا هو يعني يعني
ملح نوعا ما بالنسبه للجانب التركي كيف
نفهم هذه الموافقه
مع موافقتي على ما تفضل به الدكتور خليل
عناني اضيف ايضا ان ربما تحصل تركيا على
رفع حظر كندي لبيع الاسلحه وعدد من
المنتجات الاخرى انما الاهم وايضا كما
تفضلت حضرتك هناك مساله الاقتصاد التركي
نعلم ان الاتحاد الاوروبي ليس بصدد ضم
تركيا اليه في السابق كان الامر معقدا
والان اصبح اكثر تعقيدا مع صعود تيارات
اليمين المتطرف ووصولها الى السلطه في
اكثر من بلد انما يمكن لتركيا ان تفاوض
الاوروبيين على رزمه اتفاقات تبدا من
موضوع النزاع مع اليونان قضايا قبرص
التركيه كل منطقه بحر المتوسط الشرقيه
فيها توترات تركيا اوروبيه يمكن للاتراك
ان يحصلوا شروطا فيها خاصه في ظلمه يحكى
عن انابيب النفط وال
وبعض الصراعات على السياده المائيه وطبعا
هناك مساله اللاجئين التي يمكن لتركيا ان
تعيد التفاوض مع الاوروبيين على منحها
مساعدات من اجل التعامل معهم وضبط حدودها
كما يمكن للاتراك ان يفاوضوا على تسهيلات
تجاريه مع اوروبا وتسهيلات لتاشيرات
الدخول للاورب للاتراك الى اوروبا مع طبعا
قضيه الاستثمارات الاوروبيه في تركيا هناك
مجموعه امور يمكن لتركيا ان تعوض عن عدم
دخولها الى الاتحاد الاوروبي من خلالها
واظن هذا سيكون بحثا مضنيا ربما لكن قد
يبدا بعد اجراءات دخول السويد اضافه طبعا
الى كل ما ذكر سابقا حول الاسلحه وحول
موقع تركيا استراتيجي في هذا التحالف
وهذا مهم جدا دكتور ماجد ربما اعود اليه
في سياق هذه الحلقه ولكن اذهب للسيد خالد
خليل بالنسبه لسياسه الباب المفتوح التي
يريد ان يكرسها
بالنسبه لهذه الدول وايضا في العالم
ما الذي يعنيه
توسع الحلف الان بانضمام اسود اليه وقبله
فنلندا خاصه بان هذه الدول التي تنضم الى
حلف الناتو هي ليست دول عاديه هي دول ذات
موقع جغرافي سياسي جد مهم هي على ابواب
روسيا
هذا صحيح لحد بعيد استاذ سلمى ان احنا
نتحدث عن اكبر تحالف دفاعي في التاريخ منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه على الاقل بنتكلم
على الاقل على 30 دوله وتتم
ضمة هناك كما تفضلت وقلت سياسه وتسعين ان
الافاق مفتوح للدول الاوروبيه
بالانضمام الى هذا الحل لكن ايضا على جانب
الاخر هذا الاتساع
يعني يثير مشاكل كثيره جدا او امور كثيره
جدا الامر متعلق بالعلاقه مع روسيا نعلم
جميعا ان روسيا ترفض الى حد بعيد انضمام
اي دول جديده خاص المحاذيه لها على الحدود
وجزء رئيسي لحرب الطحينه الدائره حاليا في
اوكرانيا متعلق فقط مجرد ابداء نوايا من
النيتو قبل عده اعوام بامكانيه انضمام او
ضم اوكرانيا التي تقع الحدود الموازيه الى
روسيا الامر الاخر متعلق
باعاده تعريف هيكل الامن الدفاعي داخل
اوروبا والذي حدث على خلفيه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا عندما راينا وشاهدنا تحول
نوعي فيما بميزات الدفاع لدى الدول
الاوروبيه دول تتخلى عن الحياد خاصه في
فنلندا والسويد يعني على سبيل المتماثل
هناك اتفاقيه موقعه منذ اخر قرن 19 بين
السويد وبين روسيا تضمن شكل بقره الحياد
السيود على دخولها في حروب مع روسيا هناك
على الاقل حدود تصل الى 1400 كيلو متر بين
فنلندا وبين روسيا وبالتالي ان تتخلى هذه
الدول عن حيادها وعن هذه علاقه بنتكلم عن
تحول نوعي كبير جدا يعيد رسم العلاقه مع
روسيا الامر الاخر متعلق ايضا بما يطرحه
البعض وهذا امر مخيف للغايه وامكانيه ان
يتم يعني اتساع مساحه خارج اوروبا حتى
وقرانا وسمعنا على مدار الشغل الماضيه
امكانيه ضم اليابان على سبيل مثل مثلا
كوريا الجنوبيه ايضا دول اخرى انما كره
الجنوبيه نعم وهناك ايضا الدول العربيه
تاخذ صفه دول من خارج حلف الناتو كالكويت
مثلا وقطر ودول اخرى وبالتالي هذا الامر
قد ينبئ بشكل او اخر بدخول العالم في
مرحله جديده جدا تقوم على تقسيم العالم
النيتو من جهه وما دونهم من جهه اخرى
وبالتالي عدم حدوث نوع من السلام العالمي
كما يامل الجميع يعني الانتقال لربما
لمجموعه من الدول من حاله الحياد الى حاله
الانحياز هذا امر رحبت فيه بطبيعه الحال
الولايات المتحده دكتور زياد هذا الانضمام
وهذا التوسع ضمن هذه السياسه سياسه
الابواب المفتوحه خاصه لهذه الدول
ويعني تحدثت عن مكافات ربما لتركيا كالاف
16 وايضا ترحيبها باعاده احياء او فكره
انضمام تركيا للاتحاد الاوروبي كيف نقيس
اذا ما اردنا قياس الرؤيه الامريكيه برؤيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي كيف يمكن مقارنتهما
يعني طبعا
الانضمام الى حلف الناتو هو عكس ما كانت
تريده روسيا في حربها وهذا يظهر فشلا
كبيرا ايضا في الحرب الروسيه وهو ما تريد
تظهيره امريكا ومعها اوروبا الغربيه
بالقول ان كل ما كانت تدعيه موسكو من ان
حربها استباقيه بسبب احتمالات توسع الناتو
ها هو يتوسع عبر فنلندا والسويد وموازنات
الدفاع فيه ترتفع والرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون
كان عده في حاله موت سريري فهو اليوم
يستعيد سياقه ويصبح اكثر تماسكا بالنسبه
للاوروبيين هناك تحدي مزدوج اولا
الاستمرار في الانخراط ضمن هذا التحالف
لكن في نفس الوقت تطوير قدره اوروبيه
رادعه من دون الاحتياج الدائم الى واشنطن
لكي لا تبدو العواصم الاوروبيه ملحقه
بالبيت الابيض بالقرار الامريكي موازنه
الدفاع الامريكيه هي الموازنه الحاسمه
اليوم في حلف شمال الاطلسي
القوى الاوروبيه والصناعات الاوروبيه غير
كافيه حتى الان لاقامه مظله امنيه اوروبيه
انما البحث الالماني الفرنسي مع ايطاليا
واسبانيا ودمنا الشكل الجديد الذي يتخذها
هذا التحالف يهدف ايضا الى ان تكون اوروبا
مستقله امنيا ولو ان الامر صعب ويتطلب
وقتا طويلا طبعا موضوع تركيا يختلف ايضا
بين امريكا واوروبا منذ زمن واشنطن ترحب
بانضمام تركي وكانت تريد ان يتوسع الاتحاد
الاوروبي نحو شرق اوروبا ووسطها في حين ان
الغرب الاوروبي تحديدا برلين وباريس دائما
على حذر لاسباب اقتصاديه ديموغرافيه مركز
الثقل يريدان ان يبقى برين باريس من دون
ان يكون هناك مركز ثقل اخر في وارس او في
دول ثانيه الموضوع التركي هناك العمال
والمهاجرين الاتراك في اوروبا هناك
البضائع التركيه المنافسه بشكل جيد لبضائع
اوروبيه وهناك ثقل الديموغرافي التركي اذا
اصبح الاتراك مواطنون اوروبيون كل هذا
تاخذه اوروبا بعين الاعتبار في ظل تصاعد
ايضا خطاب عنصري وهوياتي يفضل ان يبقي على
الحدود كما هو بمعزل عن الاعتبارات الاخرى
انما الاقتصادي
ربما بتطوير العلاقه فقط هذه الجمله التي
تحدثت عنها ربما الاوساط الاوروبيه وليس
اعاده احياء مثلا المسار انتقل الى الموقف
دكتور خليل عناني الى الموقف الروسي من
خطوه انقره طبعا روسيا تحدثت بانها ربما
طعنا بالظهر هي تشكل طعنا بالظهر من قبل
انقره واكدت ايضا يعني انها يعني يجب عدم
وج ود اوهام لدى انقره بانضمامها الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكنها حريصت ايضا على
انها لا زالت مهتمه بتطوير العلاقه مع
انقره كيف لموسكو ان ترتب هذه العلاقه
الان مع انقره وفي عمليه اعاده تموضع تركي
في هذا الحيز الجيوسياسي
انا اعتقد ان العلاقات الروسيه التركيه
على مدار 10 سنوات تشهد بان هناك امكانيه
تتجاوز اي خلافات راينا ذلك فاكثر من مره
على سبيل المثال مثلا في حاله تدخل
العسكري التركي في شمال سوريا ووجود تنسيق
عالي جدا بين موسكو بين انقره هذا الاطار
فيما يتعلق ايضا بمساله الحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا راينا الوحيده التي نجحت شكلها
واخر في ضمان اتفاق اتفاق الحبوب واستمرار
هذه المساله من الموانئ الاوكرانيه الى
بقيه العالم وبالتالي دخول في ازمه في
ازمه اقتصاديه وغذائيه عالميه كان الامر
متعلق بوجود نوع من الثقه او نوع من
العلاقه الجيده بين بوتين شخصين وبين
وبالتالي موقف روسيا بشكل او باخر مما
يتعلق بامكانيه انضمام تركيا لاتحاد
الاوروبي موقف ياخذ في الاعتبار امرين
الامر الاول هو ان هناك بالفعل مصلحه
التركيه في هذه المساله لكن ايضا هو يراهن
على عدم قبول اتحاد الاوروبي لتركيا كما
تفضل الدكتور زياد وقال ان هناك عوامل
كثيره جدا عوامل سياسيه وعوامل ديموجرافيه
وعامل ث وعامل ايضا اقتصاديه وعمل شخصيه
انا متعلقه باردغان نفسه وانا في رايي
الشخصي انه لن يتم قبول تركيا عضوبي طالما
موجود اردوغان في السلطه هذا الامر متعلق
بعدم وجود ارتياح بعدم وجود ثقه بين
اردوغان من جهه وبين من جهه اخرى
بشكل عام تراهن روسيا على انه من الصعب
قبول تركيا دخلت وبالتالي هي تعتقد بانه
تعود مره اخرى بشكل اخر لعلاقات طيبه معها
وبالتالي رغم انك تفهم روسي لهذه المساله
هناك ايضا تعويل عن عدم نجاحها بنجاح
نجاحها وعدم قبول اوروبا للانضمام تركيا
اليها وبالتالي ليس مساحه روسيا خسران
حليف مهم هو تركيا بدل هذا الاطار ترتبط
باب مفتوح لاجل التفاوض على قضيه مختلفه
جدا قضاء متعدده عفوا واحده منها متعلقه
بالحرب اوكرانيا المتعلقه بالعلاقه مع
الغرب فانت متعلقه بالتعاون في الشرق
الاوسط خاصه يتعلق بسوريا ومناطق اخرى
وبالتالي هناك حاله
استراتيجيه قويه بلا طرفين تجعل روسيا
تتفهم بشكل او با خر موقف تركيا من الدوام
السويدي لحلف النيتو الدكتور زياد
ستدير موسكو مثل هذا المتغير السياسي ان
كان هذا التوجه او هذه الانعطافه التركيه
ايضا ضمن الملفات المرتبطه بين موسكو
وبينها وايضا هذا المعطى في
يعني هذا الانتقال للسويد الى حلف الناتو
وفي ضوء الحرب الاوكرانيه
اظن ان موسكو ليست ابدا بصدد التخلي عن كل
امكانيات تفاهم مع انقره هي تحتاجها ان
بسبب العقوبات الاقتصاديه او بسبب البحر
الاسود والموقع الاستراتيجي التركي على
مدخل هذا البحر تحتاج انقره ايضا لادوار
وساطه بين الحين والاخر وهناك الموضوع
السوري الذي هو مشترك بينهما لكن لنتذكر
ان انقره وموسكو تتواجهان باستمرار
تواجهته في ليبيا تواجهتها في ارمينيا
اذربيجان منطقه نغورني كارباخ في اكثر من
ملف ايضا العلاقه متوتره لكن هي تبقى
حيويه بالنسبه للطرفين يدرك الرئيس التركي
ان له قيمه مضافه من خلال ابقائه جسورا مع
موسكو وقدرته دوما على لعب دور المفاوض
كذلك يحتاجه بوتين لكي يبقى هناك لروسيا
مدخلا من خلال الاسود على البحر المتوسط
وطريقه ايضا
لايصال رسائل وتبادل رسائل مع الغرب حين
تستد الافق او حين تتعقد الامور لذلك
العلاقه ستستمر بين الطرفين لكن بظن ان
الحسابات التركيه الان صارت اكثر نحو
ضروره الابقاء على علاقه مع موسكو لكن
تمتين العلاقه اكثر من جديد مع الغرب ومع
واشنطن
لسبب يرتبط بموازين القوى بسبب عجز موسكو
عن الانتصار في حربها الاوكرانيه ومرور
وقت طويل على هذه الحرب واحتمالات ان
تستمر لفترات اطول يرى الاتراك انها مع
الوقت ستضعف الموقف الروسي وربما تتيح
للصين ان تكون حليفا استراتيجيا بديلا او
موازيا فهناك حسابات جديده
سيعبر عنها الوقت لكن لا اعتقد ان موسكو
وانقره ست الامور بينهما ستبقى ملفات
ساخنه وملفات اخرى تحتاج لكل انواع
التنسيق بمعزل عن الحسابات الموضعيه
والانيه دكتور خليل خطوط التماس ونقاط
الالتقاء كثيره ان كان ما بين انقره وبين
روسيا وايضا
كيف تضيء هذه الموافقه التركيه لانضمام
السويد الى حلف الناتو على جمله المتغيرات
التي تحصل في هذه المنطقه
نحن تاني مره تانيه تحول جديد فيما يتعلق
بموازين القوى داخل اوروبا توسع الفنيتو
يعني ان هناك نوع على الاقل طهريه من نوع
من التوحد نوع من الوحده الاوروبيه
الغربيه خاصه الامريكيه فيما يتعلق
بمواجهه روسيا الامر الاخر متعلق باعاده
تعريف منظومه الامن الاوروبي وبالتالي
تعميق الشراكه نفسها بعضها البعض وايضا مع
امريكا باعتبارها شريك مهم جدا في منظومه
الامن والدفاع الاوروبيه الامر الثالث
متعلق ايضا امكانيه تحول هذا التعاون
النوعي فيما يتعلق باوروبا ربما الى
التعاطي الصين مثلا هناك ايضا نوع من
التعاون بين الدول الغربيه خاصه بين
امريكا وبين اوروبا فيما يتعلق بالتعاطي
مع التهديد الصيني طبعا هناك خلاف واختلاف
حول التهديد طبعا بالنسبه لديك وتهديد
كبير جدا مثل اوروبا قد يكون اقل من بشكل
او باخر على الاقل اقتصاديا هناك نوع من
التفهم لمواجهه ما يسمى بالاكراه
الاقتصادي الصيني
محاوله الصين فرض نمط معين على الدول
الغربيه وبالتالي يسار الاقتصاداتها بقدر
من الضعف وبالتالي ما حدث اليوم من خلال
الموافقه على ضم السويد يعني ان انا اذا
مرحله جديده من العلاقات الغربيه
الاوروبيه الامريكيه تحديدا ورغم ذلك طبعا
مشاكل فقد تظهر في المستقبل القريب يجب ان
ننتظر حتى نراها الدكتور زياد هل تحسن
تركيا اداره هذه اللعبه ام لا ربما هذا
السؤال
المهم وسط هذا الحراك ووسط هذه المتغيرات
حتى الان وبمعزل عن اي تقييم لنظام
اردوغان داخليا في تركيا
قدرته على
الحراك السياسي
واداره العلاقات والتوازنات الاقليميه
والدوليه تظهر نجاحا نسبيا ان من خلال
مجموعه مصالحات اجراها في الفتره الاخيره
او قدرته على الاستمرار في لعب دور
الموازن بعلاقته مع كييف وموسكو ثم الان
المزيد من الانخراط في حلف شمال الاطلسي
بعد تباعد طال وقته خاصه عند شراء منظومه
الدفاع الروسيه والتنسيق في سوريا مع
موسكو وغير ذلك حتى الان تبدو تركيا في
موقع يتيح لها تحصيل بعض الشروط بعد
انضمام السويد كما ذكرنا في السابق ويمكن
ايضا ان على ما قد تحصله نمط علاقات جديده
تحاول فيه تغيير صورتها التي سادت في
الاعلام الغربي
وعن عن صواب او عن خطا ويمكن ايضا ان تلعب
دورا في سوريا هذه المره يكون بالتنسيق مع
الامريكيين وليس فقط مع الروس في مرحله قد
تدخل فيها سوريا في منعطفات جديده لذلك
حتى موضع التركي الان يعني مهم ان يقرا
وان نتابع
مالاته شكرا جزيلا لكن زياد ماجد استاذ
العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه الامريكيه في
باريس وايضا من واشنطن شكرا لك دكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لكما الى هنا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]